كقاعدة عامة ،
هذه ليست طريقة صنع السيارات أو كيف
يبدو مصنع التجميع أو بشكل عام كيف
تعمل صناعة السيارات ، فإن ما
تبحث عنه هو أمر غير معتاد للغاية لأن
هذا هو طباخ بوجاتي المثالي
مرة أخرى
واحدة من أجمل سيارات السباق على
الإطلاق.  بدأ تصوير الانتصار ليبدأ
قصة كيف أصبحت بوجاتي هي جوتي التي
بدأت منذ قرن مضى وتسافر عبر
موناكو سان سيباستيان مونزا ونيوبيرغ
ومن حلبات السباق إلى
شوارع باريس لندن وهوليوود ،
لكن كل هذا بدأ هنا في بلدة صغيرة
بالفرنسية-  الحدود الألمانية على
حافة المدينة على أراضي بوجاتي يجلس
شاتو سان جون وآنا رون جوري
صالة والأهم من ذلك
مظهر الأتيليه لأننا جميعًا فنانين اليوم ،
هناك رئيس تنفيذي لمدير تصميم الإنتاج
وحتى مؤرخ
يتفقون جميعًا على  شيء واحد
يختلف بوجاتي في
أتيليه بوجاتي التي تصنع واحدة من أسرع
سيارات الإنتاج تكلفة في العالم
وهي شيرين التي يختبرونها على
الطرق الجبلية الجديدة  rby لفهم سبب استخدام
كلمات مثل المنحوتات المختلفة
والتحفة الفنية لوصف
سيارات علامة تجارية عمرها مائة وعشرة أعوام ،
هو فهم الرجل Ettore Bugatti
وشيء واحد على وجه الخصوص لا
أعتقده السيد.  كان Bugatti رجل أعمال
على الإطلاق ، ولد Ettore في
عائلة من الفنانين من ميلانو ، كان والده
مصمم أثاث مشهورًا ،
وكان شقيقه نحاتًا ، وقد
سمحت لهم خلفيتهم الفنية برؤية عالم السيارات
مختلفًا تمامًا في 20
Ettore ، بنى أول سيارة له
واكتسبها بسرعة  انتباه صانع السيارات
الذي جلبه للعمل في
مصنعه في الألزاس ثم جزء من
ألمانيا قبل فترة طويلة أراد بوجاتي
شركته الخاصة وأقام متجرًا في نشارة خاصة به
بعد الحرب العالمية الأولى حيث عادت الألزاس
إلى فرنسا وأصبحت شركة فرنسية
كان لدى Bugatti ثلاثة مبادئ لشكل وتقنية التصميم
بدأها من خلال القيام بسيارات السباق ، واستخدم
هذه المبادئ لبناء بعض من
أسرع سيارات السباق شهرة على
الحلبة وبيعها التي فزت بها يوم الأحد
وقمت ببيعها يوم الإثنين ، وقمت بتصميم أدوات Bugatti ،
ومسدسات الصيد.
لم
يكن هناك أي شيء على الإطلاق لن
يفكر في
تصميمه منك  لم يكن proach ينظر إلى ما
يفعله الآخرون بطريقتك الخاصة ،
ابحث عن طريقك الخاص ،
قام Ettore بتصميم شواية bugatti
على حذاء حصان فائزه الشهير Grom
free من النوع 35 الذي أطلق عليه
أغنية نقية أو نقية الدم ثم  أتت
سيارات الليموزين المتجولة والسيارات الفاخرة
عملاء بوجاتي هم مشاهير
نبلاء رواد أعمال
عصاميون ومعظمهم من الذكور ، إنها حقيقة واقعة في
غضون 30 عامًا ، أصبحت بوجاتي واحدة
من أكثر
شركات صناعة السيارات المرموقة في العالم ، ثم
ضربت مأساة إيتور  قُتل ابنه وربيبه جان
في اختبار قيادة في سيارة السباق الجديدة من النوع
57 G الذي
توفي جين بي في أغسطس 1939 ،
مما يعني نهاية Gotti بعد أسبوعين من
اندلاع الحرب العالمية الثانية ولم نتمكن من
العودة مرة أخرى على الإطلاق.
شركات تصنيع السيارات الفاخرة الأخرى أيضًا
بعد عامين من انتهاء الحرب ،
مات إيتوري بوجاتي بسبب عدوى في الرئة حسم
مصير الشركة ، لكن طوال الوقت كان
عدد قليل نسبيًا ممن لا يمتلكون السيارات
يقودونها ويفهمون ذلك.  نتحدث كثيرًا عن
علامة بوجاتي عندما تحمصوا لأنفسهم
لم يكونوا يسمون أو
يقولون بوجاتي لكنهم كانوا يقولون فقط
viva la mark بعد ستة عقود من
الحرب ، سيلعب جيران Gottis الألمان مرة
أخرى دورًا في مستقبل الشركة
Bugatti والذي من خلال  الآن تم تقليصها
إلى اسمها فقط وتم إحياء
منقذها على ما يبدو على نقيض ذلك
، حيث حصلت فولكس فاجن فولكس فاجن
على علامة تجارية فاخرة أسطورية ، وفي
المقابل حصلت بوجاتي على فصل ثالث
يعيدنا إلى سيارة شيران التي
بنيت بروح  أتاري لأنه
تم تصميمه وبناؤه وفقًا لثلاثة
مبادئ من طراز بوجاتي الراحل
رقم واحد ، ستكون السيارات مصنوعة
يدويًا بالشكل الثاني بعد الأداء
الثالث ، لا شيء جميل
للغاية ولا شيء باهظ الثمن ، وهذا الاقتباس
يقول كل شيء عن الرجل الذي صنع
سيارات ، الملوك بوجاتي هو
تحفة فرنسية بهندسة ألمانية
وطراز إيطالي
[موسيقى]